お前さぁんトイレ行くパワー行きますよと言う
トイレ行くとトイレットペーパーってあると思うんですけど何気使うものか知ってもぅ
お尻拭いたりするまあまあそうなんですポイントペーパーのすごいところって引っ張る
と延々に出てるんですか
途切れるまでで基本的にロールをだって結構長いからずーっとずっつける訳なんですか
ね結構すごくないですか
便利ですねすごいそんなの無いじゃんだってティッシュだって来なかっ取り続ければ
出るんですけどあれは結構停まってるじゃないですか伊橋が一回一点が止まってるか
その物でてるんですけどいるとデパはもう負けば真えいえんに足が良さそうですね
ロールがなくなるまでも鋭仁続くっていうなかなかないんですよこの世界で言われて
みればそう結構トイレットペーパーが無限の可能性があると思ったんですけども
ちょっとするあるかもしれないっていうあのケースとしてコロコロって出したら
ブチってくるじゃんはい極めててそれぞれ罰金
言うの忘れてお尻拭いての通り流し忘れるって言う早くキーとそうでしたらこの
ズボンのこういう所に誰かを連れていれば挟まれずですでそのままトイレから出て行く
とてる例えばちょっと引っ張られて a ニールローリングに続いて頭いいてくれる人
それぞれパンッと良いけどあれどうかわかんないけど可能性としてね今回その事件が
おきますっ
まぁ今回僕といっのペーパーを使ったんですけど
トイレットペーパーこの心あをまずやりませれる米をするまで吹いた後にトイレ流し
忘れるたまたまズボンがここにテレパスも引っかかってそのままは説明文大きくなって
も家の外に出ますね
歩き続けるとずっとトイレットペーパーのロールが回転し続けて僕をとりあえず
ついて記します一緒に僕と一緒に外に出た人が
5トイレットペーパーここに引っかかってずっとローリングし続けてるよっていうのに
気付いてくれるのかをちょっと検証してみたいと思います
これも完全にジェットペーパーのすごい点を使った素晴らしい軽傷だと思う
なんで黙ってあーっあーっと振り返るとずっと俺はトイレットペーパーが続いてるよっ
ていう
じゃあ13日になっただけですよね伊豆気付いてくれるのかなんてなかなか起きない
事故ってふとした時に起きてしまうんでもちろんの事故が起きてしまったときにどれ
ぐらいに気付いてくれるのかなっていうのちょっと今回検証してみると思います今本当
に怒った時にしておきないよ
かあさんでは行ってみましょうよ今から
あった
に入っちゃってる人に10 f 待ってるけどこれまた良いですかちょっと待って4つ
は財布とってからといってください
いらっしゃいません
西盛
ん
米レーサー米公園なんですけれども
てもしれい
[音楽]
ためん
ああああああああああああん
[音楽]
ハリー
かーわーいーいー
なっちゃいますよ
エイ
ああああああ
なにこれらになりー
何やりすぎですよいいえ
んでしたっ
ファンディスクなにこれ
ねと入れてパーカーたかったん
[音楽]
me
うううう
ええええええ
me
だいぶトイレットペーパーついてまわって株やってい
ねどれだけ地球枯れずに伸ばせるかと